- IF YOU WANT TO KNOW
HOW IT FEELS
TO SIT ON AN ELEPHANT
SURROUNDED BY BEAUTIFUL GIRLS,
YES, IT FEELS GREAT.
THAT IS YOTTA LIFE.
- SPEND A LITTLE TIME
WITH BASTIAN YOTTA,
AND YOU MAY FIND THERE ARE
SOME PRETTY SUPER FEELINGS
BEHIND THAT SUPERMAN COSTUME.
HE'S A BUSINESSMAN,
A LIFE COACH,
A FELLOW WHO SAYS
HE AND HIS WIFE
CAME FROM GERMANY
TO FULFILL DREAMS OF THEIR OWN,
TO REACH GREATNESS.
- DON'T FIND YOURSELF.
CREATE YOURSELF.
YOU CAN CREATE YOURSELF TODAY
AS SUPERMAN
AND TOMORROW AS BATMAN
AND IN THREE DAYS
AS MICKEY MOUSE.
I WANT TO SHOW, HEY,
YOU CAN HAVE A GREAT LIFESTYLE
BUT WITH A VALUABLE MESSAGE.
YOU CAN HAVE FUN.
- BUT SOME NEIGHBORS
AROUND HERE
APPARENTLY HAVE SOME SERIOUS
FEELINGS ABOUT THE YOTTAS.
THIS HAS BEEN KNOWN
AS A PARTY HOUSE IN THE PAST,
SOMETIMES RENTED
BY CELEBRITIES.
SOME NEIGHBORS TELL ME
PARTIES HAVE POURED OUT
ONTO THE STREETS.
- EVERYTHING IS POSSIBLE.
AND IF IT'S A DREAM YOU HAD
AS A LITTLE CHILD,
IT'S NEVER TOO LATE
TO MAKE IT COME TRUE.
- IF HISTORY
HAS PROVEN ANYTHING,
IT'S THAT FOLKS FROM GERMANY
SHOULD NOT BE LIFE COACHES.
WE'VE SEEN THEIR PLAYBOOK.
MEET BASTIAN AND MARIA,
THE CREATORS OF YOTTA LIFE,
A PHILOSOPHY THAT'S EITHER
INTENTIONALLY VAGUE
OR JUST REALLY, REALLY STUPID.
THEIR GATED COMMUNITY
WANTS TO KILL THEM
BECAUSE THEY THROW
OBNOXIOUS PARTIES
AND HAVE A HIDEOUS
FATHEAD SELFIE ON THEIR GARAGE.
BASTIAN TEACHES
HIS ALL-FEMALE HOUSEGUESTS
THAT THE KEY TO LIFE IS HAVING
A TIGHT BOD, A JUICY BOOTY,
AND TONS OF FOLLOWERS
ON INSTAGRAM,
AND IT JUST GETS
MORE INFURIATING FROM THERE.
LIKE TIME-SHARES, SCIENTOLOGY,
AND ANYTHING DREW BREES
TRIES TO SELL YOU,
LIFE COACHING
IS A STRAIGHT-UP SCAM.
IT'S A TRAINER
FOR YOUR [BLEEP] PERSONALITY.
A LIFE COACH IS SUPPOSED
TO HELP YOU MAKE GOOD CHOICES.
SO IF YOU HIRE ONE,
THEY'VE ALREADY FAILED YOU.
MY MANTRA IS, NEVER BE THE TYPE
OF PERSON WHO HAS A MANTRA.
HERE'S SOME LIFE ADVICE:
QUIT BEING A BITCH.
EVERYONE WATCHING
NOW OWES ME $1,000.
BUT BEHIND EVERY CULT
IS JUST A DUDE
WHO WANTS MORE POON
IN HIS LIFE,
AND I CAN'T FIND
ANY REAL FAULT WITH THAT.
THAT'S WHY I TEST-DROVE
A BUGATTI
TO THE YOTTAS' RENTAL MANSION
IN THE HOLLYWOOD HILLS
FOR THIS WEEK'S
CE-WEB-RITY PROFILE.
- WELCOME TO "VICE":
NEWS WITH BALLS.
I KIND OF LOOK LIKE SHANE SMITH.
IT IS TIME FOR ANOTHER ONE
OF OUR EXTREMELY EDGY,
PRETENTIOUS,
HIGHLY IRRESPONSIBLE REPORTS.
WE SENT ONE OF OUR
UNPAID INTERNS, DANIEL TOSH,
TO LOS ANGELES TO INVESTIGATE
ONE WEIRD GERMAN GUY'S
[BLEEP] LIFE-COACHING BUSINESS.
- I'M HERE
IN THE HOLLYWOOD HILLS
TO GO UNDERCOVER
TO SEE IF THEY'LL ACCEPT ME
INTO THEIR
LIFE-COACHING CLASSES.
[EXHALES DEEPLY]
[DRAMATIC MUSIC]
[DOORBELL RINGS]
HI, I'M DANIEL.
I'D LIKE TO MOVE IN.
- SORRY, BUDDY.
WE DON'T ACCEPT MALE STUDENTS.
[DOORBELL RINGS]
YES? AH!
- HI!
- HI, I'M DANIELLE.
I'M HERE TO MOVE IN.
- ANOTHER BEAUTIFUL LADY
WANTS TO LEARN THE YOTTA LIFE.
- COME IN AND JOIN US.
- THANK YOU.
- LET'S GO.
- THE DISGUISE IS WORKING.
BASTIAN, MARIA, THANK YOU
FOR INVITING ME HERE.
BOTH: YOU'RE WELCOME.
- WHERE ARE YOU FROM?
- BORN AND RAISED
IN GERMANY, MUNICH.
- ARE YOU MARRIED?
- WE ARE NOT MARRIED,
BUT WE REALIZED
THAT IF YOU NAME A GIRL
YOUR GIRLFRIEND,
IT'S NOTHING WORTH IN LA.
IT HAS NO VALUE.
SO WE NAME HER--
I NAME HER MY WIFE.
AND SO IT'S JUST TO PROTECT
OUR RELATIONSHIP, BUT--
- I NAME HER MY WIFE TOO.
- [LAUGHS] YEAH.
THAT'S GOOD. YEAH.
- ARE YOU IN
AN OPEN RELATIONSHIP?
- NO, CLOSED. SO CLOSED.
- CLOSED.
- YES.
- YEAH, VERY CLOSED.
- HOW'S THAT WORK WITH SO MANY
BEAUTIFUL WOMEN AROUND?
- IF YOU ARE
IN A CLOSED RELATIONSHIP
AND YOU HAVE THE MOST BEAUTIFUL
WIFE IN THE WORLD,
PFF, I DON'T CARE
ABOUT OTHER GIRLS.
- ALL RIGHT.
DO PEOPLE STILL WANT YOU
OUT OF HERE, OR--
'CAUSE THERE'S PEOPLE
COMPLAINING
ABOUT THE PARTIES
AND ALL THE STUFF.
- IN THE LAST FOUR YEARS,
HE HAS RECEIVED 96 CALLS
TO POLICE.
- I HEARD ABOUT
THE COMPLAINTS.
I NEVER MET A PERSON IN REAL
WHO WAS COMPLAINING.
- THAT'S BECAUSE EVERYBODY
IN LOS ANGELES IS FAKE.
THEY'RE NICE TO YOUR FACE.
- YEAH.
- HOW MANY MONTHS
HAVE YOU BEEN HERE?
- WE MOVED TO LA
DECEMBER 2014.
- WHAT'S THE RENT HERE?
- $35,000 A MONTH.
- [WHISTLES]
- MM-HMM.
- YEAH, I MUST WORK HARD
FOR THAT.
- WHAT DO YOU DO
FOR A LIVING
BESIDES JUST BEING
GOOD-LOOKING?
- OH, THANK YOU SO MUCH, YEAH.
I HAVE A COUPLE OF COMPANIES.
SO WHAT I DO,
I MAKE IDEAS HAPPEN.
- WHAT'S YOUR NET WORTH?
- MY GOAL IS TO BRING
MY NET WORTH
OVER $1 BILLION
IN THE NEXT TWO YEARS.
- NEXT TWO YEARS,
OVER $1 BILLION.
- YES.
- MM-HMM.
- EXPLAIN TO ME WHAT YOTTA
STANDS FOR.
[UPBEAT ELECTRONIC MUSIC]
♪ ♪
- YOTTA IS THE HIGHEST
IN THE METRIC SYSTEM.
IT STARTS WITH KILO, 1,000;
MEGA, 10 TO THE POWER OF 6;
AND YOTTA IS THE HIGHEST
IN THE METRIC SYSTEM.
WHAT MEANS, LIVE YOUR LIFE
AT YOUR FULLEST POTENTIAL.
- I DON'T UNDERSTAND IT
AT ALL.
WHY DON'T YOU TEACH MEN?
- I DON'T WANT FAT, UGLY GUYS
LYING AROUND.
- YOU DON'T HAVE TO POINT,
BUT I KNOW WHAT YOU'RE SAYING.
- I LOVE TO BE SURROUNDED
BY BEAUTIFUL GIRLS,
SO IT MAKES FUN;
WE HAVE FUN.
- YOU LIKE TO BE SURROUNDED
BY BEAUTIFUL WOMEN?
- YES! I LOVE IT, SO...
- WHAT'S THE CLOTHING POLICY
IN THE POOL?
IS NUDITY ENCOURAGED?
- NO, THEY ALL WEAR
A BIKINI.
- ALL WEAR BIKINI, YEAH.
- VERY TASTEFUL.
- YOU HAVE TO ALWAYS
BE CLASSY AND--
- SPEAKING OF CLASSY,
A LOT OF THE INSTAGRAM PHOTOS--
ALWAYS, LIKE,
SHOWING YOUR BUTT.
- DO YOU KNOW THE STORY
OF THE BUTT?
- NO.
- I TELL YOU.
- I WANT TO HEAR THE STORY
OF THE BUTT.
- WE HAVE BEEN TOGETHER
FOR TWO WEEKS,
AND WE HAVE BEEN
IN THE BEDROOM,
AND SHE WAS DANCING
AND SHOWING ME HER BODY,
AND I SAID, "WELL, MARIA,
CAN YOU DO ME ONE FAVOR?
PLEASE TURN OFF THE LIGHT,
BECAUSE IT LOOKS SO UGLY."
AND SHE WAS REALLY LIKE,
"WHAT?"
I SAID, "OKAY,
I SHOW YOU SOMETHING."
AND I SWITCHED ON ALL LIGHTS
AND MADE A PIC OF HER BUTT.
- WHY DID YOUR ASS
LOOK SO BAD?
- SHE NEVER WORKED OUT.
- NEVER.
- "JUST DO FOR FOUR WEEKS
WHAT I'M TELLING YOU:
EAT CLEAN, DRINK WATER,
PROTEIN, WORK OUT."
AND AFTER FOUR WEEKS,
WE DID THE SAME PIC.
♪ ♪
- WHAT'S THE BEST PIECE
OF ADVICE
YOU CAN GIVE SOMEONE WHO'S
TRYING TO LIVE THE YOTTA LIFE?
- THREE THINGS.
FIRST: WHAT MEANS YOUR
PERSONALIZED YOTTA LIFE?
FIGURE IT OUT.
CREATE A DETAILED VERSION
OF YOUR PERFECT LIFE.
SECOND THING:
MAKE IT HAPPEN,
AND DON'T BE AFRAID
TO FAIL.
MAKE YOURSELF BELIEVE
THAT IT'S POSSIBLE.
- OKAY.
- AND THE THIRD THING:
START NOW, NOW.
NOT TOMORROW, NOT NEXT WEEK,
NOT NEXT--START NOW, NOW.
- YEAH.
I LIKE TO PUT THINGS OFF.
♪ ♪
- DANIELLE, ARE YOU READY
TO MEET THE YOTTA GIRLS?
- HELLO.
HI, HOW ARE YOU?
- OH, YOU'RE POKING ME.
WHAT IS THAT?
- SORRY, THAT IS MY TAMPON.
IT MUST BE SLIPPING OUT.
- SHOOTING WOMEN
WITH MY BOW AND ARROW.
YEAH!
IT'S MY FAVORITE
TRUST EXERCISE.
- OH! OOH!
THAT DIDN'T HURT
BECAUSE I DON'T HAVE A PENIS,
MARIA.
- DANIELLE WOULD BE
MUCH PRETTIER
IF SHE DIDN'T HAVE
SUCH A HAIRY FACE.
- DANIELLE, DO YOU WANT
TO HAVE SOME SUSHI?
- I WOULD LOVE TO.
- BUT WE EAT IT ONLY
THE TRADITIONAL WAY,
OFF SEXY NUDE MODELS.
- [SIGHS]
THAT IS LOVELY.
I'LL JUST GET A LITTLE
SOY SAUCE HERE.
OH, YEAH, FILL THAT UP.
HERE WE GO.
NOW, DO-DO-DO-DO.
GET A LITTLE WASABI.
HERE WE GO.
MIX THAT UP.
THERE WE GO.
NOW DIP, DIP, DIP, DIP, DIP.
AH! MMM!
- I AM ABSOLUTELY
NOT THREATENED BY DANIELLE,
SO I'VE SEEN THAT BASTIAN
CHECKED HER OUT,
BUT SHE HAS ABSOLUTELY NO ASS.
SHE NEEDS TO WORK OUT.
- WHAT'S THE BEST EXERCISE
I CAN DO
FOR A STRONGER PUSSY?
BECAUSE AGAIN, I'M A WOMAN,
NOT A GUY.
- YOU MUST FEEL
THE PRESSURE HERE.
DO YOU FEEL IT?
- I DO.
- NO, PRESS HARDER.
- THAT'S AS HARD
AS I CAN PRESS.
- YOU CAN TAKE A MONEY BATH.
- OKAY.
YOU'RE GONNA NEED
A REAL BATH.
YOU SHOULD REALLY CONSIDER
SWITCHING TO PLASTIC.
- AND NOW SAY OUT LOUD,
"I AM A PERFECT WOMAN."
ALL: I AM A PERFECT WOMAN.
- SAY IT LOUDER!
ALL: I AM A PERFECT WOMAN!
- WITH A LITTLE TRAINING
AND A HUGE BREAST AUGMENTATION,
DANIELLE CAN GO ON
TO DO GREAT THINGS.
- WOW.
- WHAT DID I LEARN
ABOUT YOTTA LIFE?
WELL, IT'S ALMOST DEFINITELY
AN EXCUSE TO TRICK SOME SEVENS
INTO THINKING
YOU'RE HOT [BLEEP].
AND I COULDN'T BE MORE DOWN.
SO I QUIT MY JOB AT "VICE"
AND DECIDED TO REMAIN
AT THE YOTTA MANSION FOREVER.
- SHORTLY AFTER OUR CREW LEFT,
THE HOUSE WAS TENTED
TO PREVENT A [BLEEP]
SYPHILIS OUTBREAK.
[LAUGHS]
NEXT WEEK ON "VICE":
CROCKETT AND TUBBS TAKE DOWN
MIAMI'S BIGGEST COKE DEALER.
[SNIFFLING]
- HERE'S A WEIRD TWIST:
PIXEE FOX HAS BEEN SPENDING TIME
WITH THE YOTTAS.